12 op fait mr pour douze morceaux du
répertoire pop-rock français
international 45 adhérents du projet
tous en scène de l'association multi
sont fait vibrer la salle de la tour de
voisins-le-bretonneux tous ont leur
spécialité
en fait on choisit les morceaux et
viennent se greffer dessus en fait les
musiciens qui ont envie de participer à
telle ou telle autre morceau tout
simplement
j'en connais quasiment tous plus ou
moins bien et ce qui est bien c'est que
ça change avec chaque personne n'y a une
fin avec chaque chanson il ya une
atmosphère différente et c'est sûrement
le la musique encore meilleur et le
ressenti je pense
l'association multi sont deux voisins
retenu existe depuis cinq ans avec ce
projet elle permet à des amateurs de
développer leurs compétences musicales
auprès des professionnels
l'objectif c'est de découvrir
l'instrument de l'approché de le
pratiquer de jouer ensemble et de se
produire sur scène
invité par l'association le groupe
lillois eden rock animé la deuxième
partie sur les tubes des rolling stones
ce
[Musique]